you like nice to meet a white house not
controlled by the Russian view do you
think the Senate investigation of
Russian hacking of the election yeah
you're on the committee ray you're the
Judiciary Committee ranking member along
with I'm Sharon Lindsay Graham okay so
do you think that investigation you're
starting it now we've started it will
yield actionable results I would like to
add a question to that are the
Republicans helping at all
they are Lindsay's being terrific really
yep he we had a really good first
hearing and we still have some documents
that we are waiting for and some
explanations from the FBI and he's
indicated that if we don't get what we
want
he's prepared to go the subpoena route
and I think we'll have support from our
full committee level chairman Grassley
and ranking member Feinstein so we're on
our way we've got the next hearing is
going to be on so that's what I was
getting to are Lindsay and McCain right
and they're all well they're friends of
mine and I think they're terrific
they're certainly friends of each other
they are ya know they are they only do
everything in lockstep I mean you cannot
separate them I'm not mistaken
John is called Lindsay his idiot bastard
son but he obviously means that in the
nicest possible way
yeah they're true friends but it's a
great Senate friendship that's an S&M
thing I don't think I want to get in no
no don't even go no no no don't get into
what those two call each other
Bernie do you think Trump will be
successful in dismantling dodd-frank no
they've already given up on much of that
again I think he's going to be much less
successful but what's the point and one
of the challenges indicated um the
Republican independence from him they
were intimidated by I agree with
solidarity for him in the Republican
ranks but he's pushing them to where
they can't go it Chuck Grassley there's
no rebel but he said he won't have a
hearing to confirm the Deputy Attorney
General who be the only general general
will have as long as sections has to
recuse himself and I think no he's going
to is two top appointees in this just
said they accept basically what we did
with regard to derivatives if he they do
go after the consumer Bureau I mean I I
love Elizabeth Warren I think she's
great but I don't know if she deserves
the great favor they will do for her by
letting her become a national leader in
defending the consumer girl so I think
they will make very little headway there
and they've already given up on some of
the big question who is going to beat
the Democratic candidate in 2020 we
cannot [ __ ] this up and we cannot we
also can't
live under the illusion that the
electorate is going to go for somebody
who isn't charismatic okay and a great
salesman that you can't Hillary Clinton
proved you can be completely confident
you can't win an election with I know
I'm not that great but this guy the bill
cards who I want to be like you know you
you have overdone this oh how terrible
wasn't and this great mighty Trump
it was the narrowest victory in American
history until the victory yeah but a
very narrow one and since then he is
alienated a lot of people I don't know
what world you guys live in well you
think he's so triumphant he was even the
Wolfmother
world where his president every day but
that's a totally is the world I was over
that's got nobody in the world in which
he's not just the president but he's a
politically successful and mighty
present and it's the other way around
he's losing popularity but we're not
getting anything done of course I wish
he wasn't president I worked very hard
to try and stop them but you got to
estimate where we are to answer your
question by the way it has never this
far ahead of a presidential election but
able to predict who the non-incumbent
candidate of being the party right now
I'm just yeah but I'm just I'm looking
around scouring the landscape and I see
nothing I mean III really would like and
you want to change the rock Obama at
this point like we want to be in Barack
Obama wouldn't I'll tell you how I
actually predicted it would at what year
2007 really w wonder year after not
three years before when we you guys when
he gave his IV five when he gave you a
beach boys corny in making speeches
famous speech in 2004 we could see him
rising there's I know I know I know a
guy I know a guy please
I think the people in this state duty on
doing that in Rhode Island Gavin Newsom
we gotta go
we got a guy named Gavin Newsom this guy
should be President he can win he want
to be governor in 2018 and I know that's
a short time just to be governed before
you run I don't give a [ __ ] his slogan
should be hello I must be going
nice to stop by California but I got
other things to do it I I don't think
that's gonna win back Ohio in
Pennsylvania and in the key states that
you need to get back and I look I'd love
that to be a real can Betty ho well I
don't I just don't see it as a gonna
girly you guys swirling to television a
democratic speaker in the how lame is
Helen again you know she's not a gaming
is another tennis and really have we
have Nancy Pelosi pills not there
I mean I'm you sort of popularity can
you tell her it's going to be races in
the key districts that go one way
whatever but we have the chance to win
those again any of the help stop this
manifested into I just look at the
Democratic Party and I think it's pretty
pathetic I think the way it's good up to
Trump has been rather sad and I don't
and while it's standing up the Cubs by
the way if you look at the votes in the
Senate on confirmation on the cabinet
you have the highest percentage of no
votes of any set of cabinet nominees in
history because the Democrats have been
so overwhelmingly in some cases unitedly
against them the forced rating among
health care this pessimism in this fear
you talk about all Whipple's cry you
guys are cowering before a guy who is a
paper tiger yeah he got elected but he
has been very ineffective and general
whatever what about after he starts the
war with North Korea how powerful will
he be then because once the war starts
you know presidents seem to be able to
get whatever they want I don't believe
he should have started wolf I know that
is by the way George we need have to be
crazy to do that when you start a war
with you rock and it didn't work out
very well for little [ __ ] boy he got
away we go reelected handily right
all you need and he's almost at one
where I try to shuffle deck and Barney I
don't want any other metaphysical orange
uh I was trying to get you to be calming
the way you said before
senator Whitehouse will you will you
will you believing to stop that when I
go to confirm Neil corsets I want to
hear him out first
Oh battle not wrong I don't know no no
wait answer there they stole that pick
unless the guys name is Merrick garland
agree we don't want to hear anything
else go the issue they can't they can't
you can't issue that we need to address
it's what the Republicans do when they
get five justices on the Supreme Court
and they go on a bender well that's the
new Shelby County they do that issue
tonight it the other ado Heller on and
on a Thursday that's what we need to
follow a pic Obama had a year he was
president for almost a full year the
Constitution is not ambiguous about this
the president gets to pick and they
didn't let that happen
they cannot stand the other ones who
said that for four is okay and by the
way there were a number of very good
decisions that are coming out of the
circuit courts which holding out
striking down Texas is bigoted
investigates if it stays for four that
gets upheld yeah so I hope that nobody
votes for confirming
right yeah
I think we can hold it fixes yeah all
right they try to pull the nuclear
option I think they're going to have a
real problem with that on their own you
studied that right yeah fortunately SIA
Dory but Harry Reid already Nick Newton
filibuster and last for hope not the
Supreme Court so sorry probably there's
a range of other lab they said no
Supremes they wanted by the way very
important how we agreed we had already
set a ground but just when you've
already conceded this just to show what
a different world you want to give them
every single argument I'm struck by that
what we having read did a great thing by
breaking the filibuster because you had
a very right-wing Court for instance in
watching GC overturning all kinds of
regulations one of the best things Harry
did was to break that filibuster so we
got a fair balance on the court we are
never criticized the Democratic Party
over that way yeah I just said earlier
if you were listening that Obama Obama
screwed up with the rollout I said that
the big problem to help you wrong on
that actually the rollout I mean they're
technically speaking that was incredibly
[ __ ] I want to change the subject
know anything if they ever criticize
them and I gave my critic eyes where was
this hating when we were on TV
okay I just think it's interesting that
when we hear the term nuclear option
it's always been something we've talked
about and we were talking about the
Senate and stuff like that and now when
I hear the term nuclear option I think
of what happened this week yes when Rex
Tillerson said the first strike option
is on the table with North Korea that's
a little bit of a different thing happy
st. Patrick's Day everybody I hope you
have a great week
[Applause]